[Music]
[Applause]
hi my name is Jim I'm seven years old
and second grade i like to wear with my
girls and I like math did you know a
fraction is part of a whole it works
like this if you see a pizza that's fun
to 12 slices and you take one slice you
have 112 on the whole entire pizza when
I'm done I hope you learn all the
different kinds of math and some math
vocabulary I also want you to learn how
more knife is in the entire world I have
a secret I told myself enough as a
toddler I'm even writing my own book
about adding subtracting multiplying
dividing and other numbers I'm also
going to have lots of equations in my
book math is everywhere when you buy
things start a car pick bill so time any
of when you're cooking multiplication is
used by a lot of different people did
you know we even use multiplication
that's all time not a clock it works
like this if the small hands on the
seven that means it's a new call for our
hands on the eighth that means at 7:40
is multiplication five 10 15 20 25 30 35
40 45 times 8 equals 40 the clock says
7:40 I learned how to tell time because
I kept them in frustrated not knowing
how it's done I had to play before
bedtime
but if I have to go to bed at 8:00 and
the folks at 7:49 calculate how much
time I have left in this case I have a
whole twenty more minutes to play first
raters use multiplication - for example
you couldn't tell how many kids can be
in a wasum just rules about how many
kids are at table how many tables there
are additional r1 r2 and kamee they
aren't important for example let's say
you're honoring cookies frogs at the
party with the principal you definitely
want to make sure you have enough so
our thirty students are at the party and
a hundred seventy more students join the
party
how many cookies do we need now wait
see my right breast of the school and a
thousand martinis join how many cookies
doing it now 1200 also said 1,200
another example is in science let's say
nine compulsions then kind of go okras
make nine more knives made a hundred of
course but let's say only native 15 now
I can use subtraction it's just the
office of addition to figure out how
next Republicans we have so you can
subtract the 15 potions we need from 100
Persians we have now these laws whether
they define extra fractions are all
around us too we can even add subtract
them for example if I add a clause a
cupcake they need another half of the
cupcake I've eaten three quarters of a
cupcake or when my mom makes a pie made
two thirds of the pie is only 1/3 a pie
graph for everyone else
did you know magnificent negative number
inside to a positive number and there
are more negative ones than positive
ones something negative number for
example so you lose negative 10 equals
negative 7 we're a hundred minus 200 he
was negative 100
that's pretty cool look how much there
is around us there's really a lot of
math there also questions shapes and
patterns you want to learn more about
all of this make sure to listen to
repeat hor experts math like me thank
you for listening to my presentation
[Applause]